>> Greg: YOU JUST GROANED.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE THE DEADLY
IMPACT OF THE PROGRESSIVE MIND,
WATCH BERNIE FROM LAST NIGHT’S
FOX NEWS TOWN HALL.
HE SAID HE WOULDN’T HAVE SHUT
DOWN OUR BORDERS TO PROTECT
AMERICANS FROM DISEASE BECAUSE
THAT WOULD BE RACIST.
>> IF YOU HAD TO, WOULD YOU
CHOSE DOWN THE BORDERS?
>> NO.
WHAT YOU DON’T WANT TO DO RIGHT
NOW, WE HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO HAS
A PROPAGATED XENOPHOBIC
SENTIMENT FROM BEFORE HE WAS
ELECTED.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE SCIENTISTS
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT WHAT WE NEED
TO DO.
THERE’S COMMUNITIES WHERE THE
VIRUS IS SPREADING.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
MAY MEAN SELF-QUARANTINING, NOT
HAVING PUBLIC ASSEMBLIES.
LET’S NOT GO BACK TO THE SAME
OLD THING.
ISN’T IT INTERESTING THAT A
PRESIDENT WHO HAS BEEN
DEMAGOGUING AND DEMONIZING DIM
GRANTS THE FIRST THING HE CAN
THINK ABOUT IS CLOSING DOWN THE
BORDER.
>> Greg: IMAGINE HOW CLUELESS
YOU HAVE TO BE TO SAY THAT AS
OTHER COUNTRIES ENDURE CHAOS DUE
TO VIRUS SPREAD FROM ONE TRAVEL
HUB TO THE NEXT.
HERE YOU HAVE A LEADING DEMOCRAT
SAYING SPREAD WOULD BE RACIST
AGAINST CHINESE AND ITALIANS
SOMEHOW.
ITALIANS LOCKED THEMSELVES DOWN,
YOU IDIOT.
BERNIE HAS HIS HEAD UP HIS ASS
WHILE HE’S HAIR BURNS.
SAFETY FIRST, BERNIE.
FOR A LEFTIST, BERNIE IS BEHIND
THE TIMES.
THOSE THAT CALL TRUMP RACIST FOR
BANNING TRAVEL HAVE CHANGED
THEIR TUNE TO A NEW SMEAR.
HE DIDN’T DO IT FAST ENOUGH.
BLACK, WHITE, GAY, STRAIGHT,
MALE, FEMALE, UNDERMINING
COOPERATION IN COMMUNITY WHICH
PREVENTS ACTION TO REDUCE DEATH.
HOW CAN YOU EXPECT TO FIGHT ANY
THREAT, A VIRUS OR WORLD WAR, IF
YOU LEADER WANTS YOU TO FIGHT
EACH OTHER?
FUNNY HOW BERNIE THOUGHT IT WAS
NOBODY TOLL MAKE A VACCINE FREE
ONCE IT WAS AVAILABLE.
WHY NOT MAKE IT AVAILABLE NOW?
AS IF THINGS MAGICALLY APPEAR
BEFORE THE SOCIALIST TAKES
CONTROL OF DISTRIBUTION.
TAKE IT FROM ME, WHEN A
SCIENTIST MAKES A DRUG THAT
HELPS THE WORLD, A SOCIALIST
WILL CALL HIM A BIGOT FOR TAKING
SO LONG AND THEN SMOKE IT.
LEAVE IT TO BERNIE, KATIE, WE
WOULD BE SCREWED.
THE BORDER ACTION BOUGHT TIME
FOR US TO SPREAD OUT WHATEVER
THE EMERGENCY -- THE URGENT
HOSPITAL PREP AND ACTUALLY MAKE
SOME MISTAKES.
>> Katie: HOW WE’RE BEING
LECTURED ABOUT COMMON SENSE.
SHUTTING DOWN BORDERS DURING
SOMETHING THAT IS A PANDEMIC IS
A COMMON SENSE THING TO DO.
THE PRESIDENT DID IT SOON AS
SOON AS WE KNEW WHAT CHINA WAS
TELLING NEWS JANUARY.
HE WAS CRITICIZED FOR DOING SO.
YOU CANNOT AS A DEMOCRAT OR
ANYBODY BE AN ADVOCATE FOR OPEN
BORDERS ALLOWING THOUSANDS COME
IN UNVETTED AND BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY AS A CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT WHO SHOULD BE IN
CHARGE WHO CAN DO A BETTER JOB
THAN PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN DOING SO
FAR.
BERNIE SANDERS TALKS ABOUT
SCIENTISTS.
EVERY DAY THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN STANDING UP IN FRONT OF THE
COUNTRY AND THE WORLD WITH A
NUMBER OF SCIENTISTS AND DOCTORS
THAT HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THIS DISEASE.
NOW THE MEDIA IS GAS LIGHTING
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE CALL IT A
CHINESE VIRUS OR THE WUHAN
VIRUS.
THEY’RE SAYING THAT IS RACIST,
WHICH IN RETURN ALLOWS CHINA TO
GET AWAY WITH NOT HAVING ANY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE WAY THIS
THING HAPPENED.
CAN’T TALK ABOUT HOW THIS IS
CHINA’S FAULT BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE RACIST WHICH GIVES THE
COMMUNIST PARTY A PASS FOR NOT
GIVING US THE DNA CODE OF THE
VIRUS SOON ENOUGH TO WORK ON A
VACCINE AND SEE HOW FAST IT WILL
SPREAD, ET CETERA.
SO IN IDEA THAT WE CAN’T TALK
ABOUT THE FACTS BECAUSE THEY’RE
RACIST NOW APPARENTLY CAME FROM
CHINA, IT’S A CHINESE VIRUS.
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH IT.
ALSO SAYING THAT NOT SHUTTING
DOWN BORDERS BUT ALSO I SHOULD
BE IN CHARGE OF PREVENTING THE
SPREAD OF THIS IS RIDICULOUS AND
SHOULDN’T BE TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
>> Greg: AT LEAST THE GOVERNOR
OF CALIFORNIA, GAVIN NEWSOME
ADMITTED THAT WHAT IS BEING DONE
BY TRUMP IS GOOD.
I THINK WE HAVE THIS TAPE.
>> WE HAD A PRIVATE CONVERSATION
BUT HE SAID WE’RE GOING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING AND YOU HAVE MY
SUPPORT, ALL OF OUR SUPPORT.
LOGISTICALLY AND OTHERWISE.
HE SAID EVERYTHING THAT I COULD
HAVE HOPED FOR.
WE HAD A VERY LONG CONVERSATION.
EVERYTHING THAT HE SAID THEY
FOLLOWED THROUGH ON.
EVERY SINGLE THING.
HIS ADMINISTRATION.
IT STARTS AT THE TOP.
INCLUDING THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN CONSISTENT WITH THE
EXPECTATION THAT WE REPATRIATE
THESE PASSENGERS.
>> Greg: IT’S REFRESHING, DANA,
TO SEE SOME KIND OF UNITY FROM
PEOPLE FROM DIFFERENT POLITICAL
GROUPS.
>> Dana: ALSO BECAUSE WE HAVE A
FEDERALIST SYSTEM WHICH MEANS
THE STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
THEY’RE ON THE FRONT LINES.
THEY HAVE TO COORDINATE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU’RE GAVIN NEWSOME, YOU
WANT TO FIGHT WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP OR GET WHAT YOU NEED TO
HELP YOUR PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT WHEN THINGS GET
THIS SERIOUS AND YOU’RE DOING
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS, YOU CAN
SET POLITICS ASIDE IF YOU WANT
TO.
ALSO GOVERNOR ENSLEY OF
WASHINGTON STATE HAS BACKED OFF
OF HIS CRITICISM BECAUSE THEY
REALIZE WE’RE IN THIS TOGETHER.
THE PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS HAVE
SAID THAT THE TRAVEL BAN FROM
CHINA WAS ACTUALLY VERY HELPFUL.
GAVE THEM THE TIME THEY NEEDED
TO PREPARE.
SO ACTUALLY I THINK PRESIDENT
TRUMP COULD HAVE GONE FURTHER.
HE COULD HAVE SAID NOBODY FROM
SOUTH KOREA, NOBODY FROM IRAN.
INITIALLY.
THEY WERE PRUDENT AND THEY
WAITED.
IT COULD TURN OUT THAT IT WAS
TOO LATE OR SOMETHING LIKE --
SOMEBODY MIGHT MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT, THIS IS A FAST-MOVING
SITUATION.
YOU HAVE THE BURDEN OF
LEADERSHIP WHICH MEANS YOU’RE
GOING TO GET CRITICIZED, BUT THE
FACTS WILL TELL THE FULL STORY.
>> Greg: YEAH, JESSE, BERNIE
DOES HAVE THE LUXURY OF HIS
DECISIONS NOT MATTERING.
>> Jesse: YOU CAN’T TRUST BERNIE
SANDERS.
IT’S LIKE AN ARSONIST AS YOUR
FIRE CHIEF.
YOU DON’T WANT SOMEONE THAT
STARTS FIRES.
YOU WANT SOMEONE THAT PUTS THEM
OUT.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT AN
INTERNATIONAL HEALTH SCARE AND
HE WANTS TO TAKE AWAY
EVERYBODY’S HEALTHCARE?
HE WANTS TO LOCK UP
PHARMACEUTICAL REPRESENTATIVES
FOR NOT FINDING A VACCINE.
IF YOU WANT TO OPEN BORDERS,
IT’S CRAZY.
IT’S ALL RATIONALE.
ITALY DID IT.
THEY’RE TRYING TO GET A GRIP ON
IT.
WHEN TRUMP SMUT DOWN THE BORDERS
AND FLIGHTS FROM CHINA, THE
DEMOCRATS WERE IMPEACHING HIM
AND CALLING HIM RACIST.
THEY’VE BEEN BRIEFING CONGRESS
ABOUT THIS SINCE DECEMBER.
THEY’VE BEEN PUSHING FORTH WITH
NEW VACCINES, QUARANTINES,
EVERYTHING ON TV EVERY DAY.
WHAT DO THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO DO
DIFFERENTLY?
I DON’T KNOW.
I HEARD JOE ANSWER THAT ON MSNBC
LAST NIGHT.
TWO-MINUTE ANSWER, NO CLUE WHAT
HIS PLAN WAS.
I HAD TO WATCH IT TWICE.
STILL DON’T KNOW.
>> Greg: JUAN --
>> Jesse: STILL DON’T KNOW.
>> Greg: JUAN, I REMEMBER YOU
QUESTIONING WHETHER THE TRAVEL
BAN WAS WORTH WHILE.
>> Juan: I DO.
I STILL THINK -- IT’S NOT
SHUTTING DOWN OUR BORDERS.
YOU SAY THAT.
THERE’S A DIFFERENT BETWEEN
CONTAINMENT, WHICH IS SOMEPLACE
LIKE ITALY AND SOMEONE SAYING
I’M GOING TO KEEP EVERYBODY OUT
BECAUSE I’M WORRIED THEY’LL
BRING IT HERE.
THE FACT IS THE DISEASE IS
ALREADY HERE.
OUR ISSUE IS NO LONGER ABOUT
SOMEHOW CONTAINMENT AS THE
SURGEON GENERAL SAID, IT’S ABOUT
MITIGATING THE IMPACT OF THE
FACT AND TRYING TO SLOW THE
SPREAD.
WE HAVE A SITUATION HERE IN
NEW YORK.
THEY’RE CONTAINING AN OR IN NEW
ROCHELLE.
IT’S TRYING TO CONTAIN THE
SPREAD.
THAT’S VERY DIFFERENT.
SO YOU HAVE A SITUATION WHERE,
YOU KNOW, WE HAD EBOLA COME IN
AND OBAMA WAS ASKED TO SHUT
DOWN -- YEAH, SHUT DOWN THE
BORDERS.
THE MEDICAL EXPERTS SAID NO.
THAT WOULD BE INEFFECTIVE AND
MAKE IT MORE LIKELY THAT EBOLA
WOULD SPREAD.
>> Greg: YESTERDAY YOU TALK
ABOUT HE DIDN’T SHUT IT DOWN
FAST ENOUGH.
>> Juan: THE FACT IS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW ABOUT THIS
BUT WAS ENGAGED IT’S NOT A BIG
DEAL.
WE STILL HEAR IT.
>> Katie: JUAN, IT’S SO UNFAIR
FOR YOU TO SAY THAT.
IT’S NOT TRUE.
>> Greg: THAT WAS AFTER HE SHUT
IT DOWN.
>> Juan: HE SACRIFICED ALL OF
HIS CREDIBILITY ON THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE HE’S ENGAGED IN HAPPY
THOUGHTS.
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE A VACCINE IN
A FEW WEEKS.
>> Juan: YOU WANT EVERYBODY TO
FREAK OUT AND PANIC?
>> Juan: YOU WANT SOMEBODY TO
CALM YOU DOWN.
YOU DON’T WANT -- LYING AND
MISINFORMATION, HE’S JUST NOT
GOOD AT SORT OF CALMING US.
HE’S EXCITING US.
>> Greg: NOTHING HE CAN DO.
>> Jesse: THE DEMOCRAT’S PLAN?
>> Juan: TO RELY ON THE
SCIENTISTS.
>> Jesse: SO TRUMP IS NOT
RELYING ON THE SCIENTISTS.
>> Juan: OH, NOT A PROBLEM.
GO TO WORK.
>> Greg: SHUT DOWN THE BORDER,
WHICH WAS --